la suite de ce s'études avec la première
interview on le disait il y a
Charles-Antoine albizetti qui est élève
en classe de défense et de sécurité
globale c'est un dispositif qui est
proposé du côté du lycée Hoche à
Versailles c'est un dispositif même
national un proposé par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est classe sont
une initiative voilà l'initiative d'une
équipe pédagogique qui permet de
sensibiliser les élèves qui le
souhaitent au problématiques de
citoyenneté de défense de géopolitique
et donc je le disais vous êtes élève
dans l'une de ces classes alors chaque
classe doit être parrainée par une unité
militaire quelle est la vôtre du coup
donc la gendarmerie nationale donc
particulièrement la gendarmerie
départementale des Yvelines donc qui
parraine cette classe du côté du lycée
Hoche alors au programme de l'année il y
a de nombreuses visites du coup c'est
des sorties scolaires auprès de la
gendarmerie ou c'est un peu plus global
ça va être des sorties scolaires donc
auprès de la gendarmerie ou sinon des
gendarmes qui ont présenté des
dispositifs dans notre lycée mais en
partie également à des cérémonies donc
par exemple avec le 11 novembre même
aussi prochainement avec le 8 mai donc
on peut aussi également tenir des
discours devant des ministres des mers
ou encore des préfets c'est déjà pris la
parole devant justement des ministres
des mers des préfets oui tout à fait
donc au monument aux morts de Versailles
donc notamment face à Jean-Noël Barrault
le maire de Versailles ou encore le
préfet des Yvelines je mets le barreau
qui était le député de la deuxième
circonscription des Yvelines qui est
l'actuelle ministre de la transition
numérique quel type de visite vous avez
pu faire aussi depuis le début de
l'année alors on a pu aller à Vélizy
donc avec la base aérienne de Vélizy ou
encore à Mania le hameau avec donc le
poste à cheval ou encore le psychique
donc le peloton de sécurité
d'investigation de la gendarmerie ou
encore des présentations donc de la BMO
qui présente leur forme donc leur
voiture qui permettent
donc d'échapper aux Fillard mais de
différentes types de gendarmerie avec
bien sûr la gendarmerie classique donc
la gendarmerie départementale il y a une
visite qui vous a plu s'intéresser
qu'une autre alors la base aérienne de
Vélizy qui est quand même très
impressionnante parce que c'est la base
donc de la région Île-de-France et donc
c'est très impressionnant parce qu'en
fait quasiment toutes les 5 minutes on a
un nouveau décollage d'un hélicoptère et
on peut penser que tous les hélicoptères
qui sont chez nous mais c'est pas
forcément de la gendarmerie nationale
mais très régulièrement le président de
la République prend son avion sur place
il avait pris avec le président
ukrainien à volo dimirzelinski vous avez
une question un régime ce type de classe
combien de temps ça dure ce que c'est
sur un an où on peut continuer ça se
prolonge alors déjà sur cette année en
fait c'est déjà un an et sauf qu'en fait
on a les cadets donc on sait pas encore
sur la suite sachant qu'on est en
partenaire avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et le ministère
des armées mais donc par la suite on va
continuer à participer à de nombreuses
cérémonies en faisant des discours ou
simplement étant dans dans les rangs
mais on connaît pas pour la suite et on
entend la réponse des ministères et ça
représente à peu près combien de sorties
ou de visites par an alors pour
l'instant on est à peu près une
vingtaine en compte également faire
d'autres dans la France notamment au
Mans on souhaite aller au deuxième Rima
puisque on a un projet que l'on porte
avec parce que près armée jeunesse qui
proposait par le ministère des armées où
l'on défend donc on va graver le nom
d'un ancien élève mort au combat donc au
Tchad en 1789 est-ce que ça vous
dernière petite question est-ce que vous
avez aussi des cours en plus des visites
alors oui tout à fait on a un professeur
d'histoire donc monsieur Chauvin qui
nous fait des cours d'histoire sur la
guerre donc de l'Antiquité jusqu'à nos
jours surtout que l'on voit que
actuellement la guerre frappe à nos
portes justement vous qu'est-ce qui vous
a attiré dans cette classe alors c'est
une classe qui se fait au lycée vous
l'avez intégré dès la seconde du coup
alors donc normalement c'est en
troisième mais nous que au lycée Hoche
c'est en seconde et donc on avait une
présentation de la part d'une dame du
SNU et donc moi j'ai tout de suite
et donc on a été tout de suite scotché
donc on est 30 élèves répartis sur
différentes classes de seconde et donc
je trouve que c'est important donc de
connaître des informations sur l'armée
sur plein de choses enfin qui paraissent
peut-être pas importantes à nos yeux
mais donc la base aérienne enfin tout ce
qui me permet de nous défendre à nos
yeux c'est très important et mais aussi
enfin c'est aussi de l'engagement côté
citoyen donc voilà vous disiez de
l'engagement avec une guerre qui est
revenue en Europe se confie en Ukraine
qui maintenant un an à débuter et ça
prend encore plus de sens pour vous cet
engagement aujourd'hui tout à fait
surtout que on sait qu'en 2025 un quart
des effectifs de la gendarmerie
partiront à la retraite donc enfin ils
ont besoin d'avoir une relève et donc
notamment auprès de la jeunesse
du coup vous avez aussi participé cette
année il me semble au prix armé jeunesse
ça consiste en quoi ce prix donc cette
fois on va déposer notre candidature
auprès du prix armée jeunesse donc ça
consiste à un projet donc nous ce qu'on
appelle le projet gerloto donc c'est la
personne on va rendre hommage donc il
est mort au Tchad malheureusement en
1980 et donc ça consiste à raconter tout
ce qu'on a fait durant l'année donc les
sorties les cérémonies mais aussi en
partie point des films sur la guerre
donc c'est différentes choses et on va
tenter de gagner ce prêt à mes jeunesse
pour les décisions 2023 on vous souhaite
bonne chance une dernière question du
coup est-ce que ça suscite aussi l'envie
de s'engager après là vous êtes engagé
au sein de cette classe peut-être au
sein de la gendarmerie au sein d'autres
forces de l'ordre mais ce qu'il y a une
volonté d'engagement par la suite alors
déjà tout à fait moi je vais déjà faire
le service national universel en juin
qui est proposé donc par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et par la suite je
vais voir le temps mais pourquoi pas
m'engager donc dans la journée ou en
plus large dans les armées donc avec
notamment lire ses gènes donc qui est
une donc les ingénieurs donc dans la
criminalité principalement très
rapidement l'intègre commence cette
classe commence ça se passe comment
qui est plutôt une école littéraire mais
principalement dans l'armée ou sinon
avec un diplôme d'ingénieur en intégrant
ensuite l'air CGN voilà mais pour la
classe préparatoire
la classe de sécurité globale du coup il
faut aller juste en fait c'était notre
souhait si on voulait on pouvait
participer il y avait pas de de règles
précis voilà c'est facultatif tout à
fait c'est une option bon ben merci en
tout cas d'être venu en parler sur ce
plateau Charles-Antoine albizetti je
rappelle un élève dans la classe de
défense et de sécurité globale et du
côté du lycée Hoche c'est à Versailles